ladies and gentlemen this invitation is
not to be trifle with there's been a
murder and one of you is the perpetrator
or maybe it's her or him actually let's
let detective Benoit Blanc figure that
one out that way you could just sit back
and watch the behind the scenes magic of
Glass Onion a Knives Out mystery
number one imagine being cooped up
inside for months binge watching shows
and getting a casual call to basically
work in Greece I'm making a movie in
Greece would you like to come it's like
the cast of Glass Onion were incredibly
lucky to be able to get the call and
Edward Norton was eager without even
reading a script if he calls me up
whatever it is sort of sight unseen I'm
in in addition to working in Greece the
film was also shot on location in Serbia
not such a bad gig to take number two
does Daniel Craig even know what accent
he's using in fact he really doesn't it
was a little more complicated than just
sort of like picking up a costume and
putting it on with a bizarre mix of
Mississippi and Louisiana we're guessing
Craig did indeed still give off a
stellar performance using a different
mix of dialects for each film it was
actually a little joke director Ryan
Johnson suggested Craig do before
filming began for knives out but they
decided it was best to take things a
little more seriously so it isn't a joke
blonde does not have a Discerning accent
there's also a complicated plot line
which really needed careful manipulation
whatever the right word is I don't know
of course this accent didn't make or
break the film as Daniel was mostly
focusing on bringing the character to
life number three when filming in Sea
towns across the world you have to make
sure the attire matches the setting and
costume designer Jenny Egan had a field
day designing all the Exotic tropical
outfits for the cast Egan was brought
back from the first film which had a
drastically different costume wardrobe
for obvious reasons the Wardrobe needed
a big change plus it'd be way too cold
to wear a bikini in New England Jenny
explained I felt like it could go to an
absolutely new exciting place where I
didn't have to be married to anything
except Benoit Blanc and even he is
completely different I just wanted to
make as much as I could to make it
really special and make a splash and
make these characters so individual your
clothes are almost like self-expression
and and Jenny knows that to like the nth
degree number four does it ever bother
you when somebody cuts you off it did
for Daniel when he performed those long
monologues to the group of wealthy
suspects I said I don't want to split
these up he implored Johnson to allow
him to power through these long
sequences which is understandable
because it would be hard to keep the
same emotional tone over multiple resets
of takes I wanted it to be as consistent
as possible you keep using my voice this
was just one of the many things Craig
did to help him stay in character the
other thing he did well we'll get to
that a little later just keep an eye out
for a Walkman around the set number five
Waits they did not give an actor a real
weapon on set right it's a real spear
gun I was just terrified to be like
holding it after hearing of Madeline
Klein's wild experiences on this set
much more on that soon we can't imagine
what it would have felt like to hold a
loaded spear gun near so many crew
members and actors number six the
incredibly lucky Madeleine kicks off her
Blockbuster role with a very awkward
encounter my first scene with Edward and
I was so nervous but it doesn't end
there Ryan thought it would be a
wonderful idea for her to hug Norton
during the scene born uncomfortably long
time talk about getting comfortable
around your idol fast number seven we
have one thing to say in honor of
Daniel's acting career
halliburrick any of you Daniel Craig
fans know he's got to sneak in
hollybury's name in all of his
performances although nobody really
understands why he says it this cast
sure got a kick out of it every time he
said it as detective block
[Music]
number eight it has to be incredibly fun
knowing who the perpetrator is in a
mystery and just being able to throw off
any sleuths in the audience there are
definitely moments where you look and
I'm holding my bag in a very suspicious
way Jessica henwick revealed that she
had a little too much fun adding subtle
facial expressions and gestures in some
of her scenes just because it felt it's
kind of good to feel like the bad guy
for a moment like all good murder
mysteries every single person is exactly
right so some aren't even noticeable at
first glance but you bet your detective
hats that we will be watching it over
and over again to catch these improvised
moments the movie doesn't hinge on the
oh aha that person right it's a roller
coaster ride number nine you remember
that Walkman we mentioned right did you
see them listen to his Walkman because
he was like he needed to stay in
character to get into that right mindset
for his character Daniel would listen to
music on his Walkman all the time it was
rare to ever spot him without it if he
didn't have his music playing and like
something to Center him he would get
distracted as you may know this is not a
rare thing for actors to be doing on set
but of all the tech in the world James
Bond still uses walkmans number 10.
Madeline may not have to worry about
this film flopping but she sure does
have to worry about belly flopping in
the near future I definitely belly
flopped I knew it this just looked so
painful
ouch diving into a pool is just not her
strong suit here number 11 for a film
with such an incredibly talented cast
you'd think that would already be a lot
for director Ryan Johnson to handle but
you really couldn't have an epic mystery
without the late and great Angela
Lansbury and Steven Sondheim we all
should be familiar as to why Angela was
featured her role is Jessica Fletcher in
Murder She Wrote was iconic for its time
but would you like to guess as to why
Steven was written in Brian explained
that Sondheim has a massive connection
to the murder mystery genre he was a
puzzle and mystery nut he co-wrote with
Anthony Perkins the last of Sheila which
our film takes a huge part from in terms
of the setup number 12 you'd think that
after every project Johnson has done
he'd have no trouble with something that
has little to no effects but he did in
fact have the most trouble when it came
to framing up the ensemble cast on
screen so he referred back to the grades
for help like Steven Spielberg is the
modern master of how the stage is seen
number 13. wow an actual film based in
reality so many projects that were
filmed during the covid-19 pandemic have
already reached audiences but only a
small few actually acknowledged what was
happening in the real world since Glass
Onion is set in the present day and
masks were still mandatory on set he
found a better way to incorporate it
number 14. Netflix pulled out the big
bucks for knives out can you guess how
much they paid for just the rights of
the series no not 200 million not even
300 but a whopping 450 million dollars
not to mention this doesn't even include
the budget it would take to make the
movies so we can be reassured that
Knives Out will return a lot more in the
near future number 15 we're ready for
the next one please with that big
Netflix deal we just mentioned Ryan
Johnson became eager to begin the next
installment to me the idea for the next
one is it's about just trying to create
something that surprises us and thus
hopefully will surprise the audience and
we'll Delight the audience hopefully
there's not much more other than that
but we did get a little inside scoop by
producer Ram Bergman regarding its
status so the good thing he is very
motivated to go do the next one as
quickly as possible but you know we'll
see how fast he is but this is gonna be
a challenge it's gonna be a bigger
challenge so we'll see how long it's
gonna take it's a good thing Ryan
Johnson and the rest of the cast made it
incredibly difficult for you trailer
Watchers out there to uncover it so soon
if you were cast in the next Knives Out
mystery would you rather play the
perpetrator or the victim let us know
secretly in the comments